Hey this is Presh Talwalkar. This puzzle is making the rounds on Facebook.
In fact, one of the times it was posted,
it was shared more than 400,000 times.
The puzzle is: Can you fix the equation 6
+ 4 = 4 by moving exactly one matchstick?
In these puzzles there are typically some ground rules.
You cannot break any of the sticks.
You must make a valid equation with an
equals sign. And in this particular
problem, you should restrict yourself to
numbers that you can display using seven
segments. These are the block numbers
from 0 to 9.
Can you figure it out? Give it a try
before watching the rest of the video for the solution.
So one way you can solve
this problem is by making the equation 0+4=4.
You take this matchstick and rotate it 90 degrees to
make the number zero. So you end up with the valid equation 0+4=4.
There's also another solution, you can
make the equation 8-4=4
To do that, you take this stick from the
+ sign and join it to the six. Now you
have 8-4=4 which is also valid. These are the two solutions I know.
Are there any other solutions? Let us know in the comments.
Thanks for watching this video, please subscribe to my channel I make videos on math and game theory.
You can catch me on my blog
Mind Your Decisions which you can follow
on Facebook, Google+, and Patreon. You can
catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar,  and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links are in the video description.